des mots pour réconforter.
Afin de se dépr r r rapidement
d'un logement à l'autre
en sillonnant la ville et
d'autre choix que de prendre
son véhicule.
Un coup d'oeil au panneau,
à son compte avec des collèguese
sera salée.
- C'est vrdes...2 euros! Quand e
retourne et qu'on voit deux
euros... on se dit: où on va?
C'est même pas notre indemnité
C'est dur parce que quandononons
pour 50 euros, normalement,
c'était le pletetetetetetetetete
50 euros. Là, c'est même p
c'est la moitié.
- L'essence coûtait déjà cher,
taxes, dans ce pays très
ndndndndant des importations
de carburant.
Le bouleversement uéuéuéuéuéuéue
en Ukraine, et qui va forcer
la France à diversifier
ses sources d'approvisionnement
énergétique, n'arrange
évidemment pas les choses.
Certains n'achètent que
10 euros, 20 euros.
- Y'a que les gens
qui peuvent faire le plein,
maintenant.
Bien oui, moi...
- C'est quand la dernière fois
que vous avez fait le plein
de
- Il y a peut-être un mois
et demi.
- Devoir payer plus cher
ou se serrer la ceinture :
des priorités, des grandes
préoccupations des Français
en pleine campagne
présiddu premier tour de scruti,
le gouvernement leur accor
un petit répit... à la pompe.
4 mois...le prix sera à la
baisse : de 15 à 18 centimes,
le litre. Environ 20-25 cennes.
Cela s'inscrit dans le plan r rs
milliards d'euros présenté
mi-mars. Ce
qu'il aurait peut-être
dû attendre.
- Je viens de faire le plein,
174 euros. Si je l'avais fait
demain, j'aurais gagné 10 euros
une baisse à la pompe.
- Réduire un peu le prix de
le premier avril a surtout l'air
d'une mauvaise
pour celui-ci.
l'impression de se faire
'o'o'o'o'o'o'on prenne le gazoi,
qu'on prenne l'essence, qu'on
fasse les courserererererererers
de partout
- Comme d'autres, Jessica Lobo
fait ce constat :
à la sortie du confinemen
oioioioioioiois pas la différen.
- L'infirmière devra continuer
à faire des cho p p p p p p p p.
- Tout est calculé dans ma vie
personnelle parce qu'il faut
que je garde pour mon travail,
- Pas question de réduire
eseseseseseseses visites.
- On a une dévotion en tant
qu'infirmière où. . . . . . . .e
doit d'être là et on se doit...
on a un rôle à tenir et
un devoir à faire auprès d'eux.
déterminée à exercer encore,
coûte.
- En avant, voilà, le corps.
Impeccable, ma belle! Su
Radio-Canada,
dans les Alpes-Maritimes.